you might not think copper is worth more
than a penny but in today's global
economy it's actually worth a lot for
electric vehicles Windmill Farms even
the power grid itself copper is
essential and in short supply
at the start of the next decade we're
going to have a shortfall of over 5
million metric tons
here's why the metal has become so
important and how a severe shortage is
threatening the global push toward
electrification electrification
essentially means moving away from
relying so much on fossil fuels for our
energy needs copper is critical to
electrification because it has the
highest conductivity of any non-precious
metal that's important when trying to
make an electric car or windmill
efficient so electricity isn't lost in
transit so copper is actually used in a
great quantity for these electric
vehicles and other renewable energies
much more so than what you would use in
a traditional fossil fuel power plant or
traditional cars EVS require an
estimated four times as much copper as
gas-fueled cars wind and solar Farms
also typically need about twice as much
copper as coal power plants just to
demonstrate how much copper is needed
for electrification by 2031 we're going
going to need over 35 million metric
tons of copper and Supply on the other
hand is supposed to lag behind a 30
millimetric tons for decades our nation
has failed to meet the climate crisis
with the urgency it demands Kamala
Harris is talking about the inflation
reduction act which has pumped federal
funds toward green energy and
electrification
to the law you basically get tax credits
and also other support if you are
involved in the making of you know wind
farms or factories that are making solar
components and whatnot and obviously
since copper is such a huge component of
that it's helping the prices for that as
well in May copper was trading at a
little over three dollars and fifty
cents a dramatic increase from previous
years and those prices could continue to
rise Goldman Sachs estimates that demand
for green uses of copper drives seven
percent of global consumption today up
from Just 4 in 2020 and will account for
a whopping 47 of total demand growth
between 2023 and 2040. so it's no
surprise that copper is the word on
mining Leader's lips copper exciting
copper development we're choosing to
prioritize copper
it sparked a flurry of consolidation in
the industry glencore BHP Rio Tinto and
Newmont have all made moves to buy up
other minors they've realized that
copper is going to be in such a huge
need over the next decade or so so they
have decided to instead go by other
miners to get quick access to their
deposits and get them producing in the
market much faster but all of this
consolidation can't create more copper
to find more companies need to open new
minds which is very expensive what we're
not going to do is simply go out and buy
a stream of copper analysts say that
copper prices would need to rise to
fifteen thousand dollars per metric ton
to attract investment in new mines today
prices are around eight thousand dollars
a ton
and starting a new mine can take a
prohibitively long time
Deutsche Bank estimates that projects
that start applying for permits today
will take around 10 years to reach first
production and that's just the
permitting process that's not even
getting to the production part so just
imagine how long it would take for you
to get any single like mine in the
producing stage plus new and current
Minds have also faced heightened
scrutiny on environmental and social
grounds there's increasing amounts of
environmental under a social undress
with regards to them being online
especially as we've seen recently in
some countries when they're trying to do
that
in response to looming shortages some
companies are looking to change their
products for example Tesla is changing
the makeup of battery packs to cut
copper usage in their EVS that means we
need only about a quarter as much copper
in the car as would be needed for a 12
volt battery but these changes may not
be enough electrification is only
expected to
and with it demand for this non-precious
metal
and that's going to be a thing that's
going to Define uh you know commodity
markets for the rest of the decade and a
lot of people are also saying that this
right now is the next big bull run in
quality markets